now metro police have made multiple
arrests in connection to a series of
commercial burglaries in the west part
of the valley christian costas joining
us live in studio with more on what the
suspects were looking for and how they
were able to arrest them bryan metro
police tells us they've made five
arrests within a two-day span thanks to
several leads from the community they
say the suspects were targeting close
businesses that had gaming inside
police say burglaries began in may but
it was the last two incidents on south
fort apache road and del webb boulevard
that helped move the investigation
forward the first happened on via brazil
steakhouse on south fort apache july
10th police say two men smashed the
front door and robbed the slot machines
at the bar
in less than two minutes they left with
three cash boxes the second incident
happened july 21st when two men entered
miller's tavern on del webb boulevard
they left with eight cash boxes police
say they were able to identify a vehicle
which helped locate the suspects
during the colbit and during the
commission of these crimes obviously our
suspects were
wearing masks it was very hard to
identify
but we were able to do that and quickly
police identified sean patrick from
henderson as one of the suspects who
according to reports is a 14-time
convicted felon others named in the
police report are tad massarang and eric
johnson who was driving a stolen vehicle
well police tell us this investigation
is far from over so far only patrick
faces four charges but police tell us
they are waiting for additional charges
to be filed christian casa is 8 news now